currently half the country has no
accountability or ability to reason
and it's just a coincidence half of the
people are women
[Music]
uh this is such a this is such a trap
right here okay all right one two three
[Music]
welcome back to another exciting episode
perhaps the most exciting episode of yes
or no before I introduce my guest
would you like to be my guest you can be
you can be the host you can be the guest
you can have your friends involved when
you get the yes or no game right now
from the daily wire merch shop it's a
beautiful game you go to dailywire.com
shop we ordered a thousand copies of
this game just to test it out it's sold
out like that and then you weren't able
to buy one for Christmas I'm sorry but
you can pre-order now we've ordered a
few more copies than a thousand they're
all going to sell out pre-order right
now dailywire.com
shop and then you can feel like I do
playing this game with
one and only
Benjamin Shapiro
we produce a game with your name on it
I know you had been I don't know half of
what goes on at this company I just
thought you were plotting a game like
clue where I die that's obviously in
development yeah can we do that yeah HR
HR forbids okay fair enough okay now you
were drinking
this is a peanut butter whiskey sounds
delicious it does it sounds very pretty
excited about it honestly okay first
thing I've been excited about at this
company
I can't even tell you I'm sorry
when it's a woman on the show the lady
goes first since you're a man I will go
first I appreciate that thank you first
question
when we first met I just knew that we
would spend the majority of our adult
working lives together
so you have to answer how how you think
I would answer okay
um all right
yes yeah so one
two three
of course yeah I mean I I figured that's
how you would answer that but I think
that's because you're a very optimistic
and personality mirroring fella and so
literally every person that you meet you
think that's the case
100 like it will be at an event it'd be
ten thousand people like I'm gonna spend
the rest of my life with this guy
I think that's actually fairly accurate
did I get it right you did you did I did
because you said this is a world with a
good and loving God governing everything
and therefore I get to spend my working
life with Michael yeah no I I I actually
I would have I would have assumed it
just because Jeremy is the one I believe
who introduced us and it was at
Cleveland's house and I was like God
the chances that I'm not working with
this guy yeah exactly like it's over
it's over well no we're only supposed to
drink if we get it wrong oh okay well we
can also drink it we go right okay well
I I like that rule
um
it's good stuff it's a nice Martini okay
you're up okay here we go
okay
I'm supposed to answer this how I think
you will answer this yes
Michael's wife is a doctor
oh
well and obviously you would say yes
because you know the etymology of the
word doctoral means a teacher yeah I
know I'm now now wait right not it now
huh now what do you can she can she
diagnose me with anything other than
like a missing literature degree or
something like what did you know no I
don't but
but you wait hold on are you conflating
are you saying that am I also Dr Michael
are you are oh yes you are I'm a Juris
doctor you are you are a Juris doctor
and you're a teacher to millions of
people on your show you're you're a
doctor much like Dr fauci that guy's not
a doctor Dr fauci Dr Jill is totally a
doctor doctor she's the greatest surgeon
that's true she's an amazing doctor she
is and the president and and she
probably is the right that's true yep
okay well I may have gotten that wrong
okay but either way I'll drink uh okay
I'm up
marijuana was the gateway drug to the
fall of the West
whew I have a kind of edgy answer here
but I'm not going to so I absolutely
what Michael would say about this
um
one two three
yeah no I think that if eminent
I'll bet Michael goes with LSD
that's like really like the Timothy
Leary like LSD I was thinking about
albigensianism was the gateway drug oh
yeah you're really going obscure here
okay fine it's not like the actual drug
fine okay but yeah no I I don't think
that marijuana was the gateway drug to
the fall of Western I think it was more
symptomatic than uh than causative but
if we're speaking only about drugs
there's been only about drugs and I
think that's fair and that's fair and
you're right about acid that is LSD
those were the only drugs I was really
interested in trying I never tried them
never tried anything harsher than the
Peruvian parsley but those those
interested me because they said
you see you see all these things and
dimensions and I realized yeah you do
you probably see demons well you know
it's it's sort of marijuana was a drug
that sort of was from the ground up in
terms of usage and and LSD was more like
the intellectual Elites are using LSD
and therefore all drug uses okay and the
Beatles are using LSD and that means
it's really cool so I think that I would
say I'd go with LST I really liked
McCartney had this great reaction to LSD
which is I guess John wanted him to do
it and then McCartney because he said
John said you know it changes your brain
you're never the same and McCartney said
well you know I kind of like my brain I
don't know if I want to change my brain
I thought I had that thought too as a
kid I was like
I don't know I'm not I'm not some Adonis
right I'm not gonna be um like lifting
big rocks in my life so if my brain gets
broken I'm just completely screwed if I
do remember that time when you were
eating nothing but meat in the LA office
in a desperate attempt to bulk up for a
movie we never made I do remember that
so well you weren't an Adonis I do
remember you and all that happened to
you is you got slightly fatter I didn't
actually get I got more than slightly
right you did not get more muscular no I
just look fat so I I gained I gained 20
pounds and none of it was muscle
aren't you supposed to be like I'm so I
I followed a regimen for this movie that
we never made I followed a registered
bag of meat and a pizza I would eat an
extra large pizza almost every day and
so I'm sitting there eating I did cut my
body fat I actually did my body fat went
down but I became like a big fat guy and
then but then I made one mistake which
is you know you're supposed to bulk bulk
bulk I was wearing they're not supposed
to cut right well see that's the trick
and I never quite
made it to that but I'm glad I at least
fundamentally changed my body chemistry
for a movie that never happened yeah
that was good all right yeah okay
thank you
I'll drink to that memory
foreign
ly half the country has no
accountability or ability to reason and
it's just a coincidence half of the
people are women
the wisdom of Jack Nicholson ah this is
such a this is such a trap right here um
it's a trap mainly because I have to
answer for you right you have to answer
for me yeah the answer for you
yeah currently half the country has no
accountability or
ability to reason it's just a coin and
it's and it's just a coincidence
that half of them
it's it's kind of weird I assume it's
being sarcastic so
yeah okay all right all right one two
three
that's right I think Knowles is more of
a sexist than he thinks I am this is
basically how this comes down I was just
gonna say no because it's not a
coincidence uh right okay so now yeah
exactly right
the acceptance by the way in that card
at the very least you have to
distinguish married women from single
women yeah yeah well
when a man and a woman come together
they unite as one flesh
and so therefore one does not
distinguish between qualities that would
be attributed to the man I don't know
I'm just asking for clarification what
I'm all I'm saying is that when married
women vote Yes in more family oriented
yeah and conservative ways than single
women but you you went directly too well
this is this husband is the master of
his household and the owner of his wife
so I didn't really expect you to go that
way but do you there's been this debate
that's cropped up in some recent years
which is should we repeal the 19th
Amendment or not and you know and he's
having this debate except for you it's
mostly Ann Coulter right it's mainly and
but I I brought it up to Elisa and I I
said
you know should the argument that Anne
is making is if we repeal the 19th
Amendment she would lose her right to
vote but but the country overall would
vote in a better way right statistically
because the women would vote for Dems
and uh but then there are these other
proposals what if what if we go back to
a time when it's only families or voting
you know only one family but then I
thought well that totally screws us over
because then all the single people
outnumber us and then they're going to
win all the elections but but what if
it's quite the opposite what if it's
only single women lose the right to vote
and married women get I mean why don't
you just move on to the next question I
don't care because it's Mr trap dude
it's just a trap okay uh the acceptance
of sex robots dolls is a necessary step
toward limiting sex work and criminal
pedophilic Behavior it's actually kind
of serious hmm that's true
um
that is kind of a you made me think
about it too long like if I just started
to think about it I've been like
naturally there but
um
okay here we go all right one two three
I think you're gonna make the
affirmative case that that is that it in
fact it is necessary no I actually I say
no the reason I say no even even though
you know the sex bots like Austin Powers
they seem kind of titillating and
everything the reason I say no is
because the the argument presumes that
human beings are like steam engines we
just have to blow off steam right but
that's not actually how Vice and virtue
work advice and virtue work where you do
you do more advice and you want to do
more like you do drugs you want to do
more drugs you do more virtue and
hopefully it's slightly easier so if you
give a bunch of weird sex people all
these dolls to do whatever they want
with I don't think it's going to make
them better
I think it's going to make them just go
further into their depravity okay so
watch as I make the the counter argument
so the counter argument is that the
amount of sexual sexually aggressive
behavior by single men has gone down
over the course of time to a certain
extent because they are locked up in
their rooms with their computers yep I
mean I think that you you can make that
argument now does that mean it's moral
or good no I think all of it is bad and
I think the solution to all of it is
virtue and marriage but St Thomas and I
guess Saint Augustine make a similar
argument about prostitution where they
say there it's sometimes misinterpreted
that they're saying we should have
legalized prosecution which is not what
they're saying but the argument against
outlawing prostitution is that if if you
don't have some outlet for these lustful
men then Society will just be convulsed
by the way I think that this is the
direction that Society will move almost
inevitably anyway because I think that
we're like five seconds away from the
left basically deciding that pedophilia
is a form of sexual identity you mean
minor attraction minor attraction yeah I
think the left's gonna go for that in a
matter of about 27 seconds ago
that's bad
all right
I wish everyone would just shut up about
seed oils
okay okay here we go
one two three
oh no
um
well I hate them I love talking about
them you like talking about I'm this is
a kind of a somewhat recent conversion
for me I've never bought into any diet
fad or any of these hippie
seed oils are of the devil they are the
cause of every problem in the world wow
almost almost I would say 99 I am so
I'm so one over on this now your wife is
a doctor so obviously you know that well
I mean I assumed it was crap but then I
just missed it like every other stupid
idea that I ever heard also I'm sick of
people making products from things that
that don't produce that product
naturally like like oats are not for
milk and and I never get down on it and
neither neither are almonds and neither
are soybeans no as it turns out none of
these things produce milk and so if you
give me a glass of milk that is made
from a thing that doesn't produce milk
I'm suspicious if it doesn't have Udders
right like olives produce oil and seeds
generally do not produce oil so I don't
know what seed oil is or do you know
what you know what canola oil actually
is oh no it's called rape seed
wow it is it is that's the name all the
others what soybean oil all these other
oils that that are
and when you want to stop using them you
can't they're in every food they're in
every single food I saw one I was
perhaps turning the frogs gay like
probably yeah I I looked at one product
in the grocery store are they making the
chicken sterile well that in fire a fire
is also turning the chicken yeah I'm
turning them to like crispy little
nuggets on their in their hatcheries not
the avian flu but I was in a grocery
store and they had a thing of some seed
oil nonsense and it said it called it
plant butter
plant butter where do you get the butter
from this is no that's terrible that's
terrible yeah okay well I'm gonna drink
to that there's no seed oil in my
Martini that's for sure
no there might be in the peanut butter
okay
I'm taller
but we can't stand up too I'm taller
it's I'm taller so you have to say do I
agree with that statement oh do you
agree with the statement that you are
taller yes but who is the eye right
exactly the detective becomes very yeah
I'm I'm taller so you should right it's
the answer as though as I said right
correct okay ready get set go
oh I think we're going to have to move
that really you think you're taller oh
yeah but you certainly think that you're
taller because all guys absolutely every
guy under six foot at least under six
foot is will you'll they'll say hey how
tall are you and you say like I'm 5
10.034 that's true I'm pregnant it
totally depends also on how you're
wearing your hair so right now you are
wearing like a pompadour you've got like
the John Kerry you've got at least four
inches yes I do I mean like it's like a
beehive from the 1960s
they're actual creatures living there
there are yeah sweet little groupies
like from the 1960s yeah or there's like
a rat under there and it's controlling
how you cook yeah one more Height please
give me a little okay
we'll never know until the game is over
and then we'll be lying down on the
floor just sloshed I was hoping to
finish the sentence in that way okay
here we go
Satanism is protected under the First
Amendment
okay ready what I think you're gonna say
what do you think I'm gonna say but I'm
actually somewhat unsure of what you
would say yeah
okay ready get set no
you're correct and I don't think
Satanism is protected under the First
Amendment the first amendments for
political speech yeah that is what it is
for and by the way it's not protected on
the state level it's protected first of
all I don't believe in the incorporation
Doctrine so there's that for people who
don't okay so the First Amendment of the
United States Constitution says Congress
shall make no law abridging the freedom
of speech it does not say anything about
States making laws abridging the freedom
of speech now many states have their own
Provisions along these lines but
abridgement of speech are
extraordinarily common at the local and
and City level even at the state level
role of American History right exactly
the the notion the founders were sitting
around like we have to protect the
satanists the satanists must be
protected is is absolute absurdity they
wouldn't have considered it freedom of
speech they would have considered it
essentially the same as pornography I
think yeah um and so I I would have a
hard time believing that the founders
were sitting around being like we have
to protect Satanism yeah and and so
especially not under freedom of religion
which they would have thought freedom of
religion encompassed you know known
religions it didn't Encompass things
like worship of the devil we were just
talking about John Locke who he has this
he gets a worse rap than he deserves
because he's he's sometimes described as
the he's not Jon Stewart Mill they make
him out like he's Jon Stewart yes yeah
and he's he's really not and especially
in the the essay concerning Toleration
uh Locke says we need free speech
everyone needs to have some free speech
except for those damn dirty atheists who
should be totally ostracized from
society it's kind of based you know sort
of Base John Law alrighty okay
all right okay I am more than 50 certain
that Atlantis was a real place and was
destroyed by a natural disaster oh okay
I know what you're gonna say here you
know what I'm gonna say I don't know
what you're going to say I mean we
should put this on yeah yeah I'm very
Atlantic I'm very semiotic spilled like
there's no but
that's correct no you're anti I'm
anti-atlantis are you are you Pro uh
literal the word is problematic but are
you pro-historical flood uh uh
historical Regional flood okay not
historical Global flood okay but
Regional could Encompass the entire
Middle East uh it could encompass
Mesopotamia okay okay I guess because
there's a similar narrative in the Epic
of Gilgamesh yeah so yes and and other
um yeah another and other
contemporaneous account so yeah okay
okay all right fairness that's fair
enough we'll we'll get you on Atlantis
you know for
oh this is gonna be an easy one for for
both of us here we go you ready Catholic
Doctrine in its current form including
papal infallibility mariology and
transubstantiation can easily be found
in pen numbers and enumerations in the
Old and New Testaments
welp oh hold on I wanna I wanna make
sure that I read every word of that
properly
in conjunction with yeah okay yeah okay
ready set set yeah go
oh Ben you got it wrong really okay so
which part of it is not in there you got
it wrong it's not found in penumbras and
I mean it's it's directly in the text
yeah of the Old Testament when it's not
written explicitly in the 1200 years
before Christ yes but it is written and
in the type of and in the prefiguring in
the prophecy of and then Christ in the
New Testament says Peter here are the
keys to the kingdom of heaven what you
bind on Earth will be bound in heaven
what you loose on Earth would be loosed
in heaven where is the emanation there
buddy it's right there in the text
whatever Protestant wrote that question
Ben Davies
outrageous I like that you just
restricted to the New Testament I like
that he's not like the Old Testament
also yes in the five books of Moses yeah
clear references to papal infallibility
five books well people in film all right
maybe not people well
I'm not sure I haven't given anything I
certainly would say that there are
references to Christ in the in the five
books of course you would but yeah but
but I but people I by the way would not
and it's just for the record that's that
I'm surprising everyone here but but
what about the Hat man what do you think
about the Hadith where is it yeah we
haven't even gotten into the Hadith or
thesaurus okay so before this turns into
a crusade why don't we uh
is it like okay this is mine
we
oh great
this one kind of applies to me too
though we've all done things we aren't
proud of and no one should feel
embarrassed for dabbling in
libertarianism in their Wayward youth
um
um uh
no one should feel embarrassed
it's a very dabbling and libertarianism
uh I'm gonna go with
meaning meaning I think that you
would say that people should be
embarrassed first yes correct and I
think that you don't think people should
be embarrassed so I think that
everybody should be embarrassed for
being wrong so yeah so the answer is I
don't think that you should be I I I
think that it is semi-natural for 18 to
25 year olds to dabble in libertarianism
yes and also you should admit that
you're wrong
like well I'm big on embarrassment so I
I like embarrassment like I think the
big embarrassed for things that you've
done in the past that were stupid I
think is generally a good thing that's
why again I have a giant list on the
website of like the stupid things I've
ever said I didn't know if you were
going to go soft around libertarianism
uh no I mean I think that libertarianism
is an ideology that requires lack of
real on the ground understanding of how
human beings work and when you're young
yes it's attractive specifically because
of that yeah in the same way that homo
economics is you know yes yes like I
understand it I understand as a model
also
it's not quite operative in the real
world right that's a great point because
it's you know there's that old line if
you're not a liberal when you're 17
you're right but I do think it
you could say it about libertarianism
libertarianism is the easy way out right
libertarianism is like you don't want to
be a busybody so you just say hands off
yeah and all your friends are like well
he is a Libertarian so he's leaving us
alone and so it's very it's very easy to
be casual about that yeah yeah and uh
yeah I mean again I get it I have a lot
of friends who are Libertarians
we all did we all had we all had that
phase we all had that phase you know
yeah I know I always I refer to it and I
did at the time as like it's a way to be
able to say look there's something wrong
with the modern crazy left
and I'm kind of a conservative but I'm
not like that I'm not like the bad kind
of right it's more like they won't call
me judgmental if I just say yeah do what
you want to do on your own time kind of
thing okay pour one out for the
libertarian days wow that's very funny
my early career hairstyle was worse
I think that's the first question that's
had a picture it is it is
um
okay huh all right so what would I think
you would say you would answer what I
would answer okay
um I'm gonna say okay ready get set go
I agree and I think we can all I think
we can all agree that that early
hairstyle was worse because the thing is
in my MSNBC show for all the criticisms
that have been made of it and my
pantsuits and my glasses
I felt my hair was always just totally
on has your hair ever changed I feel
like your hair has been this way since
we've known each other yeah it's been a
long time so I feel like I mean even
what's really weird when your gender has
obviously yeah but I think that you're
what's really weird is so I could say
just even had I not looked at the
picture my hairstyle has not changed
since I was six I've had the same
haircut and previously before that my
hair was just a little bit more to the
side but it was almost these yeah
oddly enough though the same could be
said of the picture it's it's always
kind of it's all been in the same
general right now again I don't think
your hair has changed all that much my
hair has changed dramatically because
for most of my youth I was like how do
people get their hair to stay up like
that and I didn't realize that people
use product in their hair this was just
not like a did you not use any product
when I was a kid no oh well I was like
is it Tim right now my dad never used
product and my dad doesn't care I mean
you know my dad my dad does not care
about his appearance at all he's at a
little drop of vanity not none right
like I have to convince him that he
should wear suits that like are remotely
his size kind of thing and so I didn't
understand that people wore product in
their hair and then when I discovered
this magic I was like ah yeah your hair
doesn't have to look like floppy Hitler
hair yeah
yeah I mean there's there's so it's very
edgy that's like that's like punk rock
era yeah they've had been slightly more
email it might have worked but it just
didn't work instead of just like clean
cut okay yeah if Nick Cannon and if Nick
Cannon in the documentary Hebrews to
Negroes taught us anything it's that
Jesus was black because he was Jewish
[Music]
what's a conditional
if it taught us anything
[Laughter]
because it's a conditional yeah yeah I
feel like uh
um if I am gonna go I'm just gonna go no
on that because there's literally
nothing to any of that Jesus
like yeah basic symbolic logic here then
yes then I mean yes that's true yeah
also Jesus was not black and he was
Jewish and
that documentary is crazy it's also if
this is some this is a again this is
like the pedantic episode with well I
mean is it not going to be
yeah exactly if a Christian wrote that
card as many Christians often do they'll
say Jesus was this Jesus was that if you
were a Christian you believe that Jesus
Christ is alive is resurrected is a lot
ascended bodily into heaven so you'd use
the present tense you would say Jesus is
Jewish are you right I don't think you
would say Jesus is black unless you
watched the Nick Cannon documentary on
the Hebrews or something uh so that's
what you say well I mean would you say
Jesus is Jewish now probably not he's
Jewish in the sense that like um
trying to think of a famous convert
well what a softball yeah exactly no and
I always said that in the sense that
Andrew klavin is like right I'm oh yeah
he remains ethnically Jewish this is
something that also I mean according to
us religiously Jewish and he's got a
recipe so but we'll get into this on
another episode of Hell or not with
Andrew Clayton yes I I mean
yeah true I like it but you just made a
very extreme bet here right like
yeah
he was like oh Pascal's wager this is
like well usually there's no downside to
Pascal's wager but they're good
theoretically for Drew being pretty
significant for my people exactly yeah
no this uh this was an issue
did you ever hear people say well Jesus
he could be depicted as black or he
could be depicted as Chinese or he could
be his name and I said I even see this
in Catholic institutions and things and
it it drives me crazy because I think
the whole point is that the guy is
Incarnate right so people not being a
Christian Theologian that would seem to
be the point if he takes a specific
bodily form then depicting him as a
random bodily form seems to defeat the
purpose yes someone's otherwise may as
well just not have him take bodily form
yes and then he could be everything it's
like the increase that's what God is so
yes I was talking to a Catholic friend
of mine and he said I don't mind when
people depict Jesus as any race or
anything she's probably like an American
father-in-law he's probably a short
swordy Jewish guy I mean I think the
Middle East I think he looks like the
guy on the Shroud of Turin because I
think the Shroud of Turin is legit but
it's like the guy in the Shroud of Turin
looks like a Jewish guy yep he doesn't
look like a Native American doesn't look
like an Eskimo it doesn't look like a
Nordic Nordic yeah right that's right
it's not German yeah he's not German
yeah
there is an amazing sort of an aside now
that we're going through artistic
depictions of Jesus that have you ever
been to Iceland no I've not been to
Iceland so in Iceland there's this
church I don't know what kind it's
Lutheran or something and it looks like
a Viking ship and then in the church
there was the statue of Jesus that looks
like the most Viking Jesus you've ever
seen and then there's a prayer right
behind it on the wall and it says we
pray that to Jesus that you protect us
from the chaos and death
okay so if that had been the original
pitch
yeah
I mean I gotta be honest that's kind of
awesome okay
in 2023 it is somehow more of an
indictment to graduate Harvard than it
is to graduate Yale
uh
gotta go through all the episodes yeah
exactly
um well
undergraduate or Law School uh this I'll
just do the whole institution okay so
I'm gonna okay I'm gonna say that
it is more an indictment to graduate
Harvard than Yale I'm like I hate to say
I'm actually I don't like taking pot
shots at my alma mater even though it's
going totally nuts because I just I find
it sort of distasteful but uh
the Yale law school event where the law
school this is supposed to be the creme
de La Creme the brightest minds and they
screamed and threw a fit because Kristen
Wagoner from ADF came in to talk about
religious liberty and they behaved like
animal children jumping up and down you
know shrieking there's no good answer to
this question I think that we should
both be ashamed of our alma mater this
is the truth because like it really like
I of course I'm going to say Harvard
because that's the one I've been focused
on when I see a Harvard headline it pops
out to me because I went to Harvard Law
yeah and for you I think Yale pops out
of you because you went to Yale yeah um
but they're both they're both it may be
a selection issue it could be exactly
yeah okay it's poor old poorly live we
both should have gone to State
University Hillsdale
Ave Maria or something out of Florida
State yeah what's the one that DeSantis
is just destroying yeah um College of um
yeah I think it's new new College yeah
that's that's amazing that's that's
where all our kids are yeah Florida's
the best man okay
I'm up
the Ark of the Covenant is likely hidden
away at the Vatican or at the church of
our Lady Mary of Zion
is that the one in what's the one in
Ethiopia
asking the wrong dude and and not simply
lost in somewhere in the sands of time
okay
so we're talking about like where is the
Ark of the Covenant now yes uh so it's
basically that it's at a physical place
somewhere in the world and not just lost
at the same but I think specifically
they're asking about the Vatican the
Vatican right again he's a little
vaguely worded so do you want to just do
it we'll change it it's any physical
place it is not lost in the Sands of a
dime yes okay ready inside go
I'm kind of convinced by the Ethiopian
guys I mean I also that you know the
Christians believe that uh Mary is the
new ark of the covenant right so it's
the wording is also a little tricky yeah
for you guys but yeah but but in terms
of the the OG yeah uh I'm
hard for me to believe it just got
totally destroyed I don't know it's like
it seems very important yeah so that
there have been two major going theories
in the Jewish Community as to where the
Ark of the Covenant is one of them is
that it's buried in the Temple Mount
somewhere yeah because the the Jews saw
the Romans coming and they're like we
are squirreling this away and the
easiest place to put this is like
somewhere underneath here which has been
a going theory for a very long time uh
and then the secondary theory is that
you guys have it
to that again really yeah because it
because there have been long-standing
rumors that the Vatican
inherited much of the wealth of the
Roman Empire and so after the fall of
Judea a lot of that stuff ended up being
kept by the Catholic Church wow and
they're not big on like actually showing
their archives like here's the stuff
we've got down here yeah I feel like I
feel I feel like I would love to like
yeah because it's like you look you go
into the museums and you're like oh
there's that uh you know Raphael
painting oh they're but like I don't
know man you got the Ark of the Covenant
you're probably putting that in like the
like the special Locker area right
exactly all the and I mean if somebody
were to have it the Catholics aren't a
horrible bet considering that when you
go through Rome one of my favorite
things is where it's just a giant
Egyptian obelisk and then boom stick
across on it it's like this is ours now
that's always for us this was ours
literally you're just walking through
all this giant Egyptian obelisk oh well
now it's Christian Okay so
next time
next time you're with your people
friends yeah and yeah yeah come on I'm
cool tell me what the room is exactly oh
where's the secret room okay
the niffy lame I don't know how you
pronounce it in English Nephilim
of the Old Testament I was going to say
nebulene but I kind of like kill him
yeah I hardly know exactly
the Nifty Lim of the Old Testament were
probably also what the Greeks call
demigods or superhuman Heroes such as
Achilles Hercules or Perseus hmm
I have to try and figure out like what
you're going to say to this
um okay one two three go
like maybe
on that I'm not ident I'm not saying
like there was the specific nephewelem
that was Achilles and that but I'm just
no no they're like quasi superhero
mythical creatures yeah yeah I mean even
to the point that
I'm
I'm enough into
the relationship between symbols and the
visible tangible world that I if you
told me that Hercules was a guy or like
a kind of a guy that was walking around
and like there's a footprint over there
well I could I could believe that okay
so yeah I I go now on this obviously I'm
more of a rationalist and so my uh yeah
I think that the the passage in Genesis
where it talks about the Nifty Lim and
how they're marrying the the children of
the of men and all of this kind of stuff
that that's actually making fun of
prior idolatrous cultures because the
way that not to get into an abstruse
biblical discussion here but but not not
I cannot say right quick here's the
quick rundown quick rundown is when the
Bible says that man is made in God's
image that is a direct rebuttal to many
of the ancient texts which say the king
is made in God's image so the commoners
are not only the king is the commoners
are nothing so the Bible is making fun
of the idea that the sons of of the of
the Bene Elohim the the sons of the of
the gods or the Nephilim that these
people are like greater than everybody
else nafal literally means Fallen that's
what that's what that's what it means in
Hebrew and so the idea that there's like
this higher caste of people who mingle
with the commoners and so that it's in
it's basically attempting to rip on the
idea of class and social distinction uh
in the eyes of God
do you think there was
like to go very rationalist or kind of
modern anthropologists do you think that
it could be referring to like uh
neanderthals or anything like that I I
doubt it because again it was written
presumably like 3 000 years ago so the
knowledge of Neanderthals would have
been pretty limited but there are these
moments like Thomas Aquinas does this
where he's I think it was maybe it's
Augustine that's it I forget one of
those yeah your references yeah 50 50
shots that's right yeah yeah maybe I
think it was Augustine is walking on the
beach and he says I found a a molar that
was 40 times the size of human molars
and so people think did he find a fossil
did he find it was a tooth of a giant
was it some kind of weird
ape-like pre I don't know I just I
wonder what the historical is he a
dentist like what's this was he a
dentist yeah I don't know okay that's a
very interesting take on the Nephilim
though I like that unfortunately science
has become a more of a religion than a
tool of systematic study of the
structure and behavior of the physical
and natural world
okay one two three
indeed duh
yeah I'm not gonna drink for that one
yeah I know I mean I deserve it okay
getting close to the end of this pile uh
oh it gives an endless pile of questions
the war in Ukraine is more likely to end
in some form of nuclear strike than with
Russia conceding all land back to
Ukraine
wow those are the two binary options
yeah and does that only Crimea by the
way yeah okay let's say it does not
include Crimea Crimea is gone okay
Crimea is gone
um it's more likely to end in a nuclear
strike okay one two three
so yeah and like I I this is how I know
that you're not a complete Russia show
because even when wait you're saying
that I am not totally carrying water for
Zar Putin right exactly that's Crusade
no whenever people say like this thing
is definitely getting a nuclear strikes
like
um no it is almost certainly not almost
certainly it will not correct okay and
the other thing is like he Putin's a
shrewd guy he's a very shrewd guy he's
fair but but like
he's not completely insane right right
and that would be a completely insane
thing to do it would be nuts because he
would not know what comes next and we
would not know what comes next but it
would not be good for him it would
definitely not be good for him like
that's the one thing that is for sure it
would not be amazing that comes next for
him is the end of The Sopranos where the
screen goes that's correct okay
oh no wow okay yeah this one
your producers are just whoever created
this is just determined to get us banned
from all social media
Andrew Tate's only real crime was
trolling a mentally ill young Swedish
woman on Twitter
[Laughter]
wow wow so this one goes behind the
paywall for subscribers is what I'm
sensing right here I don't who would
ever use such a phrase I do not know
what cruel and inhumane man would ever
say such a thing at least we're not on
TV right now yeah that's that's not on
cable TV okay um
all right okay I'm gonna one two three
I'm gonna let Michael off the hook on
this one yeah
I would also say I mean look we don't
know what Tate did or whatever but he
has bragged about being a pimp fraudster
right which is like usually a good
indicator of the year Pimp fraudster is
when you brag about it a lot like that's
it by the way are you more of a
fraudster if you brag about being a pimp
fraudster or if you brag about being a
pimp fraudster and you are not a pimp
fraudster which makes you more of a
fraud I don't actually know the answer
yeah if his argument has just like no I
was totally lying about that right it's
like nights and days like are you are
you like I don't know the answer to this
question yeah well either way it was a
great martini and
do we know who won
according there was a winner I mean we
have this first we don't know but we
both won wait I think the audience won I
think the audience really won and the
YouTube sensors will now be able to
demonetize all daily wear content for
the rest of History they they want to
before that happens guys buy your game
to take home yes or no dailywire.com
shop we'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]